- Good morning, all.
Welcome or welcome back if
you've been to re:Invent before.
We are so excited you've
joined us here this morning.
So we've been busy building, innovating,
working backwards from a
lot of the conversations
and a lot of the challenges
that you've shared with us
in the last 12 months.
And we're super excited to
share everything that's new
in the world of network security
to help you protect your infrastructure.
So my name is Sofía Aluma-Santos.
I lead our go-to-market for our network
and application protection services inside
of our security organization.
And I'm joined here by my
colleague, Saleem Muhammad.
- Yes, hi. Good morning.
My name is Saleem Muhammad,
and I lead product management for network
and application protection at AWS.
Welcome to have you here.
- Awesome.
So Saleem's gonna join us in
a bit to walk through some
of the new innovations
in network protection.
But for now, I'll go
ahead and get started.
Thank you, Saleem. So...
We've been working backwards from a lot
of the conversations that we've mentioned.
Part of our role is traveling around
to different geographies, different geos,
to where you are all at,
and sharing from you,
working backwards from your perspective,
your challenges as network
security operators.
So if you're here,
we are assuming that
you are fairly familiar
with networking, network security,
networking on the cloud,
some of our security services on AWS.
And you're here to learn
more about what's new
to make your days easier
in network security
and NetSecOps, and how we can
protect your infrastructure
in a more streamlined way.
So first, we'll work backwards from some
of the challenges that we use as kind of
the North Star and the guiding
principles that we've used
to really ensure and guide our roadmap
and our security service innovations.
We'll also do a quick primer and overview
of the services that are
in scope, in discussion,
in the network and application
protection portfolio,
and then we'll jump into
everything that's new.
So as we talk through, you know, teams
in network security, you all
share different challenges
and different pain points
that you have to balance
when setting out your strategy.
The first of which,
we all know that we are not
on a single architecture type,
a single deployment, a single cloud.
You have to manage a
varying degree of complexity
in your architecture decisions.
We understand that folks might
be operating across cloud
or have to support type
of hybrid connectivity,
so you rely on us to ensure
that we match the support,
the functionality to make
sure that you're connected
in the way that you need to.
Second is also making sure
that you're able to scale
and perform and ensure
that you're able to ramp up
and down as you need to,
and you look to us to
ensure that we give you
the visibility and the ability to do so.
A lot of these security
decisions are also driven
by compliance and data
sovereignty regulations,
security frameworks
that you must adhere to,
that you must...
That we work backwards from
to ensure that you're given
the ability to prove, to do that,
and to meet those standards.
So we take all of that into
mind when we're building
a lot of our new functionality
to ensure to give you
the visibility and the
ability to prove and make sure
you're matching those compliance
and those security frameworks.
All of these decisions,
you've told us, takes a toll.
All of this takes a
cognitive load on your teams.
You've told us, Sofía,
every time we see a new
service or a new functionality,
we have to map this back.
We have to understand
how this meets our needs,
how this relates to everything
we've already deployed,
help us ensure that this is intuitive,
that this is easy to spin up.
So this is definitely
something we've kept in mind,
and it's on us to ensure
that things are easier
to start, easier to ramp up to onboard.
We're thinking about things
like interoperability,
integration, native attachments,
so we're abstracting away
things that are manual,
and you can spend less
time in that cognitive load
and more time doing things
that are your comparative
advantage and with your business.
Visibility is a key aspect to everything.
You've deployed, you've set your rules,
your policies, your configurations.
How do you know they're working optimally
to meet your use cases?
We're making sure that across the board,
we've made a commitment to
adding visibility all across
our network suite, and we're
super excited to share some
of that today.
And lastly, this is a
fast-paced, high-changing world.
Right?
In the era of AI,
how do we know what new
threats are evolving
in this landscape?
We understand that, and
given our unique perspective
with a global infrastructure that we have,
we're able to understand that,
take back the insights that we see across
our traffic patterns, and
make sure we're protecting
our local infrastructure,
our AWS underlying
infrastructure, and more and more,
we're giving you a lot of
that threat intelligence
to be able to use that
into your own solutions,
and we'll walk through that as well.
So we know there is no such
thing as a silver bullet
to security, right?
Everything is a layered
defense in depth strategy,
and we understand that
it takes a lot of pieces
that you must tackle to
ensure that you're layering
for defense in depth.
But what we're here to talk
about today is things inside
of the network and
application protection space,
and here, you can see
those here in the middle
of the display.
Now, how do you think
about those services?
We understand that sometimes
it could be challenging
to understand how these
things work together,
so let's walk through that real quick.
When you, if you think about
a typical web application architecture,
if you think about how you're organizing
and protecting your traffic as it comes
into your network, you
definitely want to start
with setting up a WAF, a
web application firewall,
and a Shield Advanced,
our anti-DDoS solution to
ensure that you're protecting
from threats that are
coming in into your network.
As the traffic is coming in,
you move into the idea of
segmenting, organizing,
and inspecting that
traffic inside of the VPCs.
So then you can leverage a service like
our AWS Network Firewall,
which is our cloud-managed
native next-gen firewall
on AWS, to do things like organizing
for east-west, inspecting
east-west traffic inside
of your VPCs, or we
have a lot of customers
that jointly with AWS
WAF use Network Firewall
for ingress inspection
and ingress use cases.
But by and large,
the biggest use cases that
we see for Network Firewall
is organizing and setting up robust egress
or outbound controls.
For egress, it is definitely
a two-part solution.
We want to ensure that folks know
to use Network Firewall along
with Route 53 Resolver DNS firewall
for that DNS path as well.
And then organizing this,
right? Organizing this at scale.
You have WAF policies, security groups,
NACLs to think about, the
DNS firewall policies,
Network Firewall WAFs.
How do you make sure that
you're able to deploy
this from a central location?
And that is where services
like Firewall Manager
come into play, where you're
able to organize these,
set these up, and configure these,
and get central visibility from one place.
And Shield Network Security Director,
which I'll walk through in a bit,
is also meant to give you
extra visibility inside
of your network resources.
And if you're more of a visual person,
if you can think about where,
as you're moving your traffic
through your typical web
application architecture,
you'll get that WAF and Shield to protect
on that ingress path,
the Network Firewall,
and the DNS firewall to
protect both paths out
on that egress.
And then the Firewall Manager
and Shield Network Security Director
for that cross management
and visibility use case.
Now, this is also the team
that ensures and manages
our AWS underlying global backbone.
So we manage and deploy
across our global presence,
and we're making additional
commitment to ensure
that you are matching the connectivity,
the performance, and, you know,
the throughput that you need to ensure
that you meet your use cases.
And with that global presence comes
an immense scale of protection.
So if you think about
everywhere we are deployed
and the sheer amount
of traffic that we see
on a daily basis,
think about these are exabytes of data
that we analyze and we see
through our infrastructure
on a minute basis,
and thousands of DDoS attacks
that we're able to mitigate
on a daily basis.
All of this comes back
into threat research
that we can analyze and learn from.
So if we think about how
we can work backwards
from threats, we know that
there are threat actors
who have threat targets and
leave behind threat artifacts
or indicators of compromise,
that we can take, analyze,
and build threat intelligence
that we can then use
to mitigate those further attacks.
But here at Amazon and our threat research
and threat intelligence teams,
we like to take a more proactive approach,
and that's the idea of
deceptive technology.
So we disclosed this project
a couple of years ago.
If you've heard of MadPot,
which is one of our threat
research projects inside
of Amazon, this is
essentially a set of decoys
that we've deployed all
across our infrastructure.
So we have tens of thousands
of decoys deployed across
our global infrastructure.
These are emulating vulnerable services
with different variations
of vulnerabilities,
and we can take that and see the recon,
the type of traffic...
We observe insights that we
see and take and learn from,
and that is integrated
and leveraged across
our existing services like
Shield, like GuardDuty.
So now I want to share
everything that's new
in network visibility.
As I mentioned, we've made a commitment
and we've understood that folks are asking
for greater visibility
across their network stack.
So, in talking to a lot of customers,
you've told us, Sofía, I
manage a central security team,
but I can only do so much
by setting guardrails,
by setting security baselines.
But I have a complex type of architecture,
a complex type of business organization.
I am inheriting legacy systems,
legacy business units with
different security teams
that are used to doing
things a different way.
So my central guardrails,
unfortunately, only go so far,
and I have to grant
exceptions to these teams.
How do I know what these
teams have actually deployed?
I also have to give my
development teams and my app teams
a certain degree of autonomy, right?
I want them to have the
autonomy to work fast
and build fast.
But now how do I know if
they've deployed correctly,
if I have things configured,
or what even exists out there?
So this is where the Shield
Network Security Director
service comes into play.
So we announced this a
couple of months ago.
It is currently in preview,
so you can try this out at no cost.
And that is essentially
the use cases that we're trying to solve.
Primary piece is giving
you that visibility
into your network.
It will first scan your
network resources and give you
a topology view of what exists.
It will give you various findings
and give you different severity
levels that you can take
a look at and triage based
upon our AWS best practices.
And we'll set recommendations
based on those best practices.
And if you have any questions,
there's an integration
with Amazon Q Developer
where you can ask things of your network
from a natural language basis.
So it's really easy to get started.
Essentially, you start a network analysis
and that will start a scan.
You'll choose the accounts
that you want to scan,
and it will show you
first that topology view.
It will show you what
is connected to what,
what the relationships are,
and you can basically
double click and drill
into each piece and those findings
and those recommendations.
It's important to note here,
we may be familiar with
similar type of topology maps.
The key thing is here,
you will see everything in
the map no matter if there
is a finding associated
with something or a type
of vulnerability or risk,
whether it's there or not.
The key thing is visibility.
So you'll be able to
see everything that is,
even if it does not have any
findings associated to it.
You'll be able to also drill
into the type of findings
and different ways.
We have different widgets and dashboards
where you'll be able to
drill into different types
of resource types, filter by those types,
filter by different severity levels.
And then this is that cue piece where,
if you choose to, this
is not a requirement
of the service, but if you choose to,
you can ask specific questions
based on your use case
to get drilled into everything
that is in your network posture.
So we've also added additional
visibility across the rest
of our firewalls as well.
The first of which is on AWS WAF.
Now we understood that you
needed additional visibility
into understanding
whether your WAF policies,
your rules were working
as you expected them to.
So this new dashboard experience gives you
that additional visibility
to where, for instance,
if you have teams that have
set all of your WAF policies
to alert mode and you are
expecting, for instance,
for them to be blocking,
you'll be able to easily
see what percentage
of your WAF estate is
set on alert or block
for easy triage to understand
why it might not be behaving
or why it is behaving,
you know, the way that you expected to.
Additionally, you'll be
able to see things like
where you're seeing
traffic hitting your WAF
and hitting your network.
So you might have and
operate in a specific region,
in a specific geo,
so you should not expect to
see traffic in different geos.
Now you'll be able to easily see those
in this dashboard experience as well.
In tandem with that,
we've reduced the price
on the CloudWatch logs
for this new dashboard experience,
so now that gives you essentially
a more predictable cost
structure for that.
Moving on to Network Firewall.
So previously we had an
open-sourced dashboard
that you could spin up
and get traffic insights
for Network Firewall.
We have now announced
a new native console
dashboard experience as well
on Network Firewall where you'll be able
to see traffic insights,
things like top talkers and different ways
to help you optimize your traffic.
For instance, things that
might be good recommendations
for a private link endpoint.
So we have customers that
may not need to, you know,
scan all their traffic
through Network Firewall.
This new dashboard experience
essentially bubbles up things
that are great private link candidates
where you can route your traffic
through that trusted private
link destination and be
on your way.
All right, moving on to
everything that's new
in the world of application
and edge protection.
So we've touched on WAF and
I mentioned we're trying
to essentially make it as
easy as possible for you
to get started and spin
up on your WAF web ACLs.
So we have revamped the creation
of the web ACL experience.
Previously it was a very
DIY type of experience.
Now we've radically made it easier
to give you protection
packs and starter packs
where we recommend rule
types for you to get started.
Additionally, just this week we launched
a CloudFront Plus Security
bundled flat rate prices.
So this includes CloudFront, WAF,
DDoS and Route 53 DNS protections
in a simplified flat rate price.
This is aimed at our founder
persona that where folks
are asking us to give them predictability
in their pricing to make
sure that they're able
to be protected and be on their way.
So new to getting started on WAF,
you'll now be able to
essentially tell the experience
what type of application
you're trying to build.
And based on that type of application,
be it like an e-commerce
or a banking application,
we'll essentially
recommend different rules
to get you started based on
that type of application.
So as previously you see far at the end,
the only experience that
before this new dash,
this new Starter Pack,
protection packs allowed,
it was only a DIY type of experience.
Now you'll be able
to leverage these new
recommended kind of configuration
packs to get you started easier.
Also new to WAF
is a new Layer 7 anti-DDoS
protection managed rule.
Now, I know we mentioned
that Shield Advanced
is our anti-DDoS service.
We have now brought in DDoS protections
as a managed rule onto WAF.
If you're a Shield Advanced customer,
this is included in that subscription.
So, you know, these work in tandem.
But this now essentially
gives folks additional
configuration and tunability, visibility,
where we were hearing
from a lot of customers
that they wanted greater visibility
into how these DDoS
protections were working.
Essentially now with this managed rule,
we're able to extend
greater configuration,
greater tunability, and greater visibility
in that Layer 7 type of protection.
And lastly, new to WAF, we've
added in this age of AI,
it's really important to
ensure that you are able
to authenticate AI agents.
So we are now leveraging
cryptographic signatures
on HTTP for verification,
and this will now automatically verify
against in the category AI bots as well.
All right.
Now I'll hand it off to Saleem,
who will walk us through
everything that's new
in the world of network protection.
Thanks.
- Thank you, Sofía.
(audience applauding)
All right.
So Sofía just provided
an overview of network
and application protection portfolio.
Then she shared some
enhancements in the space
of threat intelligence and visibility.
And finally, she talked
about some innovations
in application protection space.
Now I'm gonna focus on network protection.
When it comes to network protection,
you generally face
three unique challenges.
First is cyber threats
are constantly changing
and becoming more sophisticated,
which means that staying ahead
of these threats requires
that you continue
to adapt your defenses.
That takes us to challenge number two,
which is your teams are
already spread too thin,
and finding the right skill
set can be challenging.
This actually results in
additional time it may take
for you to detect threats, analyze data,
and take remediation action.
And this challenge is also connected
to challenge number three,
which is you need insights.
You need visibility into
how your applications
are talking to each other and outside
of your environment,
so that you can identify threats quickly
and take remediation actions.
All of this makes network
protection critical and complex.
Today I'll talk about a
couple of AWS services
that can help in this space.
First one is Amazon Route
53 Resolver DNS Firewall,
and second is AWS Network Firewall.
Amazon Route 53 DNS Resolver
Firewall, DNS Firewall,
is a fully managed service
that helps you block DNS
queries to malicious domains
and allows DNS resolution
to trusted domains.
It is a fully managed service
that you can deploy centrally
to provide coverage across multiple VPCs.
The way you can write policy is either
by creating your own custom
domain lists or using one
of the Amazon provided
managed domain lists.
The service provides
full logging capability
so that you can meet compliance
or perform your own auditing.
It also provides advanced
DNS security functionalities,
for example, protection
against DGA attacks
or DNS tunneling.
Second service is AWS Network Firewall.
This is our cloud next-gen firewall
which offers stateful inspection.
It provides IDS
and IPS capabilities as
well as TLS decryption
so you can crack open the packet, do
the packet inspection, and
then re-encrypt and send it
to the destination.
This is a fully managed, highly available,
and auto-scaling capability,
which essentially means
that as your traffic increases,
we'll automatically
add additional capacity
to your firewalls all the way
to 100 gigabit per second.
The service also supports
full logging capability.
There are two types of logs
that support flow logs
as well as alert logs.
The way you write the rules,
you can write them in alert mode
so you can get visibility, allow,
or block based on the
action that you take.
The way that you deploy
this firewall is one
to either provide protection
for ingress traffic,
basically any threats that
are coming from the internet
into your VPCs.
You can deploy it
for egress protection
across VPCs, across regions.
Or third, which is the most common one,
is egress protection
to protect any traffic
that is going from your
VPCs out to the internet.
Because this is one
of the most common deployment options
that customers take,
let's take a little bit
of a deeper dive into it.
When looking at egress protection,
there are multiple choices
that are available to you.
Some choices are free
of charge, for example,
stateful security groups
or stateless network ACLs.
We already talked about DNS firewall
to provide you protection at DNS layer.
And then you have some choices
by using middle boxes such
as third party firewalls
or AWS Network Firewall.
In some cases, there are
some customers who require
an explicit proxy.
So far, their choice had been to use one
of the third party explicit proxies
and manage it themselves.
But very recently, we
actually have a new service
that we made available.
It's a fully managed explicit egress proxy
that is offered as a new resource type
under AWS Network Firewall.
So the existing firewall,
it operates as a transparent appliance.
But this new resource type
offers explicit egress function as well.
You can deploy egress
proxy on your NAT gateway,
which makes it very simple
because a lot of traffic
is going to taking the egress path.
And NAT gateway is
generally part of that flow.
The way it works is when the traffic comes
into the proxy, you can
create pre-DNS filtering.
So essentially, it looks at the domains
and filters out any
communications that are going
to malicious or unallowed domains.
After that, the proxy
will do a DNS resolution.
Once the DNS resolution is done,
you can do another
filtering based on post-DNS information.
If the traffic is authorized,
it goes to the destination.
And when the response
comes back from the server,
you can do another analysis based on
the response coming back
from the servers and using
the header attributes in the response.
The service also supports TLS decryption,
so you can definitely use that.
It supports logging capability just like
the existing firewall resource type,
so you can meet compliance
and auditing requirements.
And basically, you can use this to perform
the same functions that
other firewalls provide,
basically to protect
against data exfiltration
or attacks that are based on malwares.
Coming back to the existing
firewall resource type,
there are two ways generally in which you
have been deploying firewalls.
One is distributed firewall deployment,
which is a form where you
deploy a firewall within VPC
and manage it as an individual resource.
Then there is another type,
which is centralized deployment,
typically deployed by a
centralized cloud infrastructure,
cloud security team, where they
will have a transit gateway.
And with the transit gateway,
you can create an inspection
VPC where you'll deploy
a firewall and route traffic through it.
It's a very scalable approach
if you have lots and lots
of VPCs and you're centrally
managing your traffic
for either east-west or egress path.
Very recently, actually
around reinforced timeframe,
we simplified the centralized
inspection process.
We actually made available
a native TGW attachment.
So within transit gateway,
you enable native firewall attachment.
We will take the
responsibility of creating
the inspection VPC, creating the firewall,
creating the subnet, and
creating the route table entries
to route traffic through transit gateway
and through this inspection
VPC and the firewall.
All you have to do is point your traffic
to the native attachment and
we'll take care of the rest.
Now, leveraging the same
capability, a couple
of weeks ago, we enhanced
the centralized deployment
model even further.
And this time, we are
taking the simplification
on the cost allocation side.
So if you are from a centralized
cloud infrastructure,
cloud security team, what
you have been telling us
is that you are processing traffic
through transit gateway and
Network Firewall centrally
and taking on the cost burden for all
of that data processing yourself.
The more your environments grow,
the more application teams
that you're servicing,
the amount of volume grows,
and then it becomes very difficult for you
to get visibility into which applications
are generating more cost burden for you.
With flexible cost allocation,
we are simplifying that entire process.
So within transit gateway,
you create a cost allocation policy.
Based on that policy,
you can attribute the cost
of data processing in TGW
and Network Firewall to
either the peer account owner
of the source attachment,
destination attachment,
or the centralized cloud
infrastructure team
that owns Network Firewall
and transit gateway.
You can create this
policy at attachment level
or more granularly at the flow level.
This native attachment
is our recommended way
of deploying centralized deployment,
because going forward, there will be
a lot more enhancements that will be added
to this kind of functionality.
Now, switching gears
towards threat intelligence,
there are a couple of things
that I'll talk about both
in the space of or in the
area of managed rule groups.
First is active threat defense,
which is an Amazon-provided
managed rule group.
Earlier, Sofía was talking about MadPot,
which is Amazon's own globally
deployed infrastructure
of honeypots or digital decoys.
Our threat researchers actually
exposed these digital decoys
as vulnerable services
to attract interaction
from malicious actors.
Through that interaction,
we learn about their TTPs
and use that threat intelligence
to protect AWS infrastructure.
You have been asking us to provide
the same threat intelligence
that we have to protect AWS infrastructure
and make it available for you
so that you can protect your
workloads and VPCs as well.
So active threat defense
is our answer to that.
This rule group is generated based on
the threat intelligence
that is exactly coming
directly from MadPot.
Once you deploy it on Network Firewall,
we will make sure that we keep it updated.
So as soon as we detect
a threat which is active,
we will add it to the rule group.
And as soon as we realize
that one of the threats
is not active anymore
and it becomes stale,
we'll remove the rule that
is associated with that.
And we do it at a 10-minute interval.
So every 10 minutes,
if there is a change
in the threat landscape
that we have visibility
into, we'll make the update.
If there is no change, then
we'll let it go. Right?
So once you deploy it,
there is no need for any manual action.
You can deploy the rule
group either in alert mode
to get visibility or you
can deploy it in block mode
to get visibility as well as take
the simultaneous block action on that.
This is exactly how it works.
In your VPCs, you have firewalls.
This firewall can be deployed
in a distributed deployment model,
basically a firewall in every VPC,
or in a centralized deployment
model with transit gateway.
The middle box is essentially
all of the processing
that we take ownership of.
Our security engineers
are detecting the threats,
they're analyzing it,
they're processing it,
they're making sure that the threats
that they have identified
are actually real.
Once we are sure of that,
at that point we automatically
update the rule groups.
Now the second area that
I wanna talk about is you
have been telling us that
when you write firewall rules,
you can of course write custom rules.
But in many cases,
you already have existing relationships
with some security vendors.
You're procuring threat intelligence
and using it either
on-prem or in other clouds
or in your firewall as well.
So the current mode of procuring
this third-party threat
intelligence and applying it
on Network Firewall has been
to use the custom rules,
which is a manual process
and adds operational burden on you.
You have been asking us to
simplify that entire process.
Recently, actually a couple of weeks ago,
we announced partner managed rule groups
on Network Firewall.
These rule groups
are based on partner
generated threat intelligence
that is available through Marketplace.
The way you deploy this is you go
to AWS Network Firewall console.
Within the console, you have
stateful managed rule groups.
That's where you can learn
about all of the partners
and their unique managed rule groups
that are available to you.
You can learn more about
what type of rule groups
that they provide, what type
of coverage they provide
within the console itself.
Once you have selected the
rule group that you want
to deploy, you hit the subscribe button
and it will automatically take care of all
of the backend functions and make
the rule group available to you.
The step after that is essentially taking
that rule group and
applying it to your firewall
and you're done.
Behind the scene, partners
are taking the responsibility.
As soon as they have a change to make
on the rule group, they will
automatically make the change.
You will not be in the
process, essentially,
you don't have to take
any kind of static action
or manual action to get
the updated rule groups.
You can deploy it either
in alert mode, once again,
just like active threat
defense to get visibility
into the threat activity,
or in block mode which will give you both
the visibility as well
as simultaneously block
the communication to the
malicious infrastructure.
There are seven partners
that have launched these
managed rule groups with us.
I will quickly cover their uniqueness,
what type of managed rule
groups that they offer
and how they can benefit
your environments.
First is Check Point.
Check Point is a global
cyber security company
that offers or provides a wide
range of security solutions.
They are a pioneer in stateful firewall
and now offer AI-powered
cloud-delivered security solutions.
Their managed rule group
for AWS Network Firewall
is based on their threat cloud AI experts
that automatically create
this rule group and make sure
that it is updated so that
you can get protection
in the areas of CVEs or
OWASP top 10 vulnerabilities.
Second partner is Fortinet,
which is a well-known
cyber security company
and offers next-gen firewalls.
Their managed rule groups are based on
the threat research that
their FortiGuard lab provides.
It's the same threat research
that is available to you
as a Fortinet customer across the globe.
So if you are using Fortinet
for example on on-prem
or in other clouds you can bring
the same threat intelligence
and apply it on AWS side as well.
They offer managed IPS rule groups
for AWS Network Firewall
that help you protect
against exploits,
vulnerabilities and C2 attacks.
Infoblox unites networking,
security and cloud
to protect you or basically integrate
with their protective DDI platform
so that enterprise can get
agility and resilience.
Their managed rule groups are based on
their predictive DNS threat intelligence.
At Infoblox's scale
with 70 billion events detected every day
or 4 million indicators every month
with 90% pre-query detections,
you get faster protection with
low noise and high impact.
Next up is Lumen
which is a global
communication service provider
that integrates products
and services in the space
of networking and security.
Their defender managed
rule group is available
on Network Firewall based
on the unique threat
intelligence that they generate
through Black Lotus Labs.
It is their own threat intelligence
team, Black Lotus Labs,
that identifies and neutralizes hundreds
of emerging threats leveraging
their backbone level visibility.
Then we have Rapid7 that
offers products and services
in the space of detection and response.
Their products include
vulnerability risk management,
attack surface management as well as
managed detection and response.
The product that they offer,
basically the managed rule
groups are self-cleaning
and expert-vetted and provide coverage
in two specific areas.
One is advanced persistent threat.
This is where they protect
against state-sponsored
or sophisticated attacks, or ransomware,
which is essentially
providing you protection
against financially motivated attacks.
ThreatSTOP is a cloud-based
threat intelligence company
that generates their threat
intelligence across thousands
of resources globally.
They convert that into actionable policies
that are made available
to you in your routers,
firewalls or DNS servers.
ThreatSTOP already offers
managed rule groups for AWS WAF.
So now they're extending
their managed rule groups
to Network Firewalls
so you can get network
layer protection as well.
Their rule groups provide
ingress protection
as well as egress protection,
and help you meet compliance
with ITAR and OFAC.
Lastly we have TrendMicro
which is a well-known scene app
or cloud native application protection
platform with expertise in
protecting your environments
in the cloud.
Their manageable groups are based on
their Digital Vaccine program,
which customers are
already using to protect
their cloud environments.
And the specialization that they offer
with their managed groups
on Network Firewall
is to protect you
against zero day attacks.
So they have a program called
Trend's Zero Day Initiative
that generates the threat
intelligence and by using
this managed rule group,
you are protected faster from the
zero vulnerabilities that are out there.
To summarize, we talked
about some enhancements
in the area of threat
intelligence and visibility.
We talked about some
onboarding enhancements
for application protection
and network protection.
We also talked about a new resource type
of explicit proxy within
AWS Network Firewall.
Before we leave, I wanted to share,
there are some additional
sessions that are available
for you to learn more about our firewalls,
ingress protection, egress protection,
and overall network and
application protection.
With that said, I hope
you found our session
to be informative and the
journey very exciting.
Both Sofía and I, we will
stick around here for a while.
If you have any questions and would like
to share your feedback,
we'll really appreciate it.
With that, thank you so much.